un
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 25 janvier voici
les titres
il permet à chaque citoyen d'être
informer orienter sur ses droits et ses
obligations de pouvoir rencontrer
notamment des avocats le point justice
de fontenay le fleury est accessible à
l'hôtel de ville bertrand monnet
président du tribunal judiciaire de
versailles sera notre invité pour parler
de l'accès au droit dans le département
c'est un geste habituel après les fêtes
de fin d'année se séparer de son sapin
mais que deviennent ils ensuite et dans
l'agglomération versailles grand parc
les arbres sont broyés redistribue aux
habitants qui le souhaitent pour être
ensuite réutilisés exemple à saint cyr
l'école et puis direction l'espace à la
fin de cette édition à la découverte du
parc aux étoiles installé à triel sur
seine le site permet d'observer le ciel
et de s'initier à l'astronomie au
travers d'animations ludiques avant de
développer ses titres locaux vides 19 et
cette information le centre de
vaccination de mantes-la-jolie va
déménager situé hall 5 du parc des
expositions le centre fermera ses portes
ce lundi 31 janvier il déménage à
magnanville au complexe sportif irma
riffaud ouverture le 3 février avec un
nombre de rendez-vous qui diminuait sur
place le lieu était jugé trop grand le
départ vers mantes de le départ de
mantes-la-jolie sera largement compensée
par les pharmacies et levac cybus
installé le lundi dans la ville indique
la municipalité au 23 janvier un million
cent douze mille six cent soixante
treize personnes étaient totalement
vacciner dans les yvelines
[Musique]
je vous en parlais dans les titres un
point justice est installée en mairie de
fontenay le fleury 17 structures de ce
type existent dans le département ils
permettent aux yvelinois d'être
conseillés gratuitement par des
professionnels de la justice du social
de l'administratif et des finances le
reportage de marc augé ions chaque mardi
matin la mission locale accueille les
jeunes de 16 à 25 ans déscolarisés au
sein de la mairie de fontenay le fleury
l'intervenante les aide dans leur
orientation scolaire et professionnelle
des fois ils ne savent pas du tout ce
qu'ils veulent faire donc on regarde
ensemble avec les différents dispositifs
conte à la disposition pour les aider à
trouver un projet si le savent déjà ce
qu'ils veulent faire on cherche la
formation la plus adaptée donc à leurs
besoins que ça soit une formation
financée par la région ou non financées
et la dent faut qu'on trouve des
financements pour les aider ou sinon la
recherche d'emploi ces services
s'inscrit au sein du point justice de la
mairie cet organisme permet également
aux yvelinois de rencontrer gratuitement
d'autres professionnels comme des
avocats des médiateurs des notaires ou
encore des écrivains publics le pont
justice ce sont 12 permanence qui sont
dans la mairie chaque semaine ça permet
d'avoir des informations juridiques sur
les devoirs les obligations de chaque
citoyen il est ouvert aux fantaisies un
héros au nom fontenaisiens un des
services est d'ailleurs très demandé
malheureusement le cidff
78 contre les violences faites aux
femmes mais les écrivains publics aux
grands succès les notaires aussi ce
point justice est le seul de versailles
grand parc la prise de rendez-vous avec
l'un des professionnels peut se faire
par téléphone par mail ou directement à
l'accueil de la mairie
on en profite justement pour parler de
cette thématique de l'accès au droit
avec mon invité c'est bertrand monnet
bonsoir bonsoir le président du tribunal
judiciaire de versailles merci d'être
avec nous sur ce plateau alors ce
reportage parler des points justice a
fait écho à d'autres noms maison de
justice et du droit point d'accès au
droit relais d'accès au droit toutes ces
structures ont été regroupés au sein
d'un même nom à saint
même la belle on peut le dire comme ça
point justice s'est fait non on peut
tout à fait dire les choses comme ça
effectivement depuis le 1er janvier 2021
ministère de la justice souhaitait
donner un peu plus de visibilité et
lisibilité
ces structures on les appelle maintenant
des points justice et elles sont placées
donc cette structure sous votre autorité
ça veut dire que ça fait partie de vos
missions de permettre cet accès aux
droits aux citoyens dans les yvelines
tout à fait c'est une mission qui est
attribué aux présidents des tribunaux
lorsqu il gère un département comme
c'est le cas dans les yvelines et ça
depuis 1991 c'est une loi de 1991 qui a
favorisé l'aide juridictionnelle est
également l'accès aux droits accès au
droit c'est en réalité un dispositif un
peu général pour parler de deux
structures qui vont permettre de
rencontrer des professionnels comme
c'était très bien dit dans votre
reportage des professionnels des
associations pour avoir des informations
un peu général mais aussi des aides à la
démarche et éventuellement un peu de
conseils lorsque ce sont les avocats les
notaires ou les huissiers pourquoi c'est
important justement de permettre cet
accès au droit en plus dans ce contexte
un peu particulier où on est dans un
contexte où il ya peut-être une défiance
vis-à-vis des institutions notamment de
la justice oui c'est vrai mais vous vous
voyez c'est depuis 1991 il ya eu deux
mouvements il ya eu un mouvement où on
sait de la justice s'est aperçu qu'il
fallait absolument qu'elle sorte de ses
murs les gens ne viennent pas
spontanément dans les tribunaux pour se
renseigner sur leurs droits ou pour voir
comment mettre en place des procédures
et donc on a décidé depuis 1991 d'aller
un peu au devant et de créer des points
répartis sur le territoire en lien avec
les collectivités parce que sans les
collectivités on peut pas faire grand
chose et donc là comme un
fontenay-le-fleury par exemple dans des
mairies dans des centres communaux
d'action sociale on a mis en place des
partenariats qui permettent
l'intervention de professionnels comme
je le disais sous le regard d'un conseil
départemental d'accès au droit que je
préside et qui comprend les autorités de
l'état la préfecture le conseil
départemental mais également les
professionnels avocats huissiers
notaires et aussi des associations à
lorient dans le détail il ya des maisons
de justice et de droit dans les yvelines
une dans le val de seine aux mureaux 2 à
saint quentin en yvelines avec deux
antennes à attraper et guyancourt il
existait également 17 points justice
réparties dans tout les yvelines est-ce
que sont le même type de structure est
ce que il ya une différence entre
maisons de justice et du droit point
justice tout le public qui se rendent
dans ces structures les choses sont
assez transparente ce sont des endroits
où on fait globalement la même chose la
seule différence est que à l'origine les
maisons de justice et du droit ont été
créés dans le cadre de la politique de
la ville dans les années 90 pour
permettre là encore d'aller sur des
territoires plus défavorisés et des
territoires éligibles à la politique de
la ville donc de reconquête en quelque
sorte pour permettre aux tribunaux
d'aller vers les publics qui étaient les
plus en difficulté
alors quelles sont les missions de ces
structures et qu'est ce que le citoyen
peut y trouver dans ces structures
concrètement selon la structure selon
son importance on y trouve comme vous
l'avez dit dans le reportage c'est
d'ailleurs assez représentatif on a
fleuri à une offre assez diversifiée on
y trouve des permanences d'associations
qui vont délivrer du conseil à la fois
en matière de consommation famille droit
du travail droit des étrangers le
surendettement soit des consultations
par des associations des juristes
d'associations soi même des premiers
contacts avec des avocats avec des
notaires là aussi pour du conseil
patrimonial fiscal par exemple ou bien
des huissiers sur des problèmes de
recouvrement de dettes d'exécution du
jugement donc tous ces professionnels
sont réunis dans ses structures et donne
une première vision de ce que les
personnes de ce à quoi les personnes
endroit éventuellement les oriente vers
un professionnel qui pourra approfondir
le dossier les oriente aussi vers le
tribunal et puis également c'est une
aide à la démarche administrative ou
d'une aide à la démarche vers les
tribunaux en particulier on le disait
les écrivains publics sont très
recherchées notamment pour remplir des
dossiers en matière d'être jury
dictionnaire puisque vous savez que les
personnes qui ont de faibles revenus
s'ils ont besoin d'intenter une action
en justice est bien peuvent solliciter
une aide de l'état qui prend en charge
les frais d'avocat et parmi ces points
justice deux points justice qui sont
dédiés aux jeunes on a deux points
justice effectivement dédiés aux jeunes
adossé au bureau d'information jeunesse
qu'ils sont implantée à chanteloup les
vignes à vélizy villacoublay
en termes d'activité ce que vous avez
des chiffres à nous donner sur le nombre
de personnes accueillies par ces
structures oui tout à fait alors je
complète peut-être le dispositif en
disant que nous avons aussi les cinq
tribunaux en réalité répartis sur le
territoire le tribunal de versailles
évidemment qui est un peuple en quelque
sorte la maison mère si vous me
permettez l'expression
également en vente la jolie poissy saint
germain en laye et puis rambouillet qui
sont eux-mêmes des points dans lequel le
public peut trouver un conseil et une
orientation l'ensemble de ces structures
pour vous donner un chiffre nous avons
accueilli dans les deux maisons de
justice et du droit en réalité 2 celle
de celle de trappes et de guyancourt et
est dit est subdivisé en deux donc dans
celle du val de seine et dans celle de
saint quentin en yvelines nous avons
accueilli en 2021 17000 personnes c'est
un accueil à la fois physique mais c'est
aussi un accueil téléphonique et nous
avons accueillis dans les autres points
justice donc une vingtaine de points
justice répartis sur le sur le
territoire plus de 26000 personnes là
encore téléphonique ou présentiel et
dans les tribunaux dans les services
d'accueil des tribunaux ça représente
2000 passage à l'année pour des
informations générales donc ça c'est
pour les maisons de justice et du droit
les points justice est également liée
aussi la possibilité de consulter un
avocat au sein des centres des restos du
coeur oui dans les oliveraies il ya un
certain nombre de restaurants du coeur
qui sont situées à faire nous liait
plaisir bois d'arcy et rambouillet dans
ces quatre restos du coeur les avocats
toujours bien sûr gratuitement organise
des permanences dans lesquelles les
attributaires des paies des restos du
coeur peuvent aussi prendre des
renseignements en même temps qu'il
qu'ils vont faire leurs provisions
pouvez vous l'avez rappelé ainsi accès
au droit et gratuit tout à fait
l'ensemble du dispositif est financé le
budget pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
le budget du conseil départemental
d'accès au droit qui finance une bonne
part de toutes ces actions est un budget
annuel de 230000 euros répartis sur de
nombreuses associations environ 20 25
associations dans des domaines très
différents et c'est ces subventions qui
font vivre les juristes qui donne des
consultations et les avocats et les
professionnels ont une contribution en
nature ça fait partie de leur mission en
quelque sorte de service pub deux
partenaires de l'institution et pour
retrouver toutes les informations sur
l'accès au droit dans les yvelines voilà
le site internet qui s'affiche pour
retrouver un aussi un tous ses sites
présents dans les yvelines merci
bertrand monnet d'avoir été avec nous en
plateau et je rappelle président du
tribunal judiciaire de versailles
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également le pic de
pollution particules fines ce mardi le
seuil d'information a été dépassé dans
la région selon airparif l'organisme
chargé de la surveillance de la qualité
de l'air en ile de france un épisode dû
aux températures basses et à des vents
très modéré une alerte qui devrait se
prolonger de 24 heures pour la journée
de mercredi il est recommandé aux
personnes fragiles et vulnérables de
limiter leurs déplacements et de
privilégier des sorties courtes et de
proscrire les activités sportives côté
route la préfecture de police invite les
franciliens notamment à réduire la
vitesse de 20 km/heure sur les grands
axes
les sept dernières années ont été les
plus chaudes jamais enregistrées selon
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
on parle de ce sujet avec philippe
bousquet directeur du lsc eux c'est le
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement et c'est notre interview
express
[Musique]
c'est pas tellement surprenant on est
dans un monde depuis la révolution
industrielle où finalement on aimait de
plus en plus de gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère avec le temps sur une
évolution qui est n'est pas complètement
linéaire qui est plutôt quasi
exponentielle mais avec des accidents
quand il ya une crise financière quoi
tiens voilà par exemple la crise
sanitaire actuelle de factiva
éventuellement freiner un peu les
émissions mais bon an mal an les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
augmentent
[Musique]
au delà de l'augmentation de température
qui est meilleur partout dans le monde
on ad on a tendance à avoir un petit
plus d'extrême climatiques notamment des
vagues de chaleur donc ça clairement et
puis une deuxième tendance est aussi un
petit peu plus d'extrême plus vieux
c'est à dire d'avoir effectivement des
précipitations un petit peu plus
abondante
[Musique]
donc nous dans les yvelines c'est un
vrai et un prêt et c'est un vrai sujet
donc le fait d'avoir les événements
extrêmes de pluie sa demande de
réfléchir comment on va pouvoir
éventuellement tester toutes les
installations qui ont été faites pour
éviter les inondations
sur la température les yvelines sont pas
trop mal placé au sens où il ya quand
même pas mal de zones boisées et voilà
aussi la zone du coup avec de l'eau donc
ça ça a plutôt tendance à atténuer
finalement les vagues de chaleur ces
zones humides où ces zones boisées et
donc c'est des zones à préserver l les
fêtes de fin d'année sont passées je
vous apprends rien on est le 25 janvier
il était temps de jeter son sapin n'est
pas n'importe comment plusieurs villes
dans les yvelines ont décidé de mettre
en place des parcs à sapin pour
faciliter la collecte le roi de la forêt
sera ensuite broyés puis redistribués
aux habitants qui le souhaitent exemple
à saint cyr l'école avec mathilde le
front des parcs à sapin disposés un peu
partout dans saint cyr l'école au total
1400 ont été récoltés ces 900 sapin de
plus par rapport à l'année dernière une
évolution due à l'augmentation des
points de collecte mais aussi grâce à la
prise de conscience des habitants j'ai
fait ça dans une démarche écologique et
le parc à sapin à côté de chez moi donc
j'ai décidé de venir le déposer dans
park à sa fin c'est très bon pour
l'environnement puisque ce qui est issu
de la nature retournent à la nature et
que comme ça on respecte vraiment le
cycle vertueux de la nature et on est
parfaitement respectueux de
l'environnement mais attention les
sapins avec encore des décorations ou
floqué ne sont pas accepter ces derniers
contiennent des produits toxiques et ne
peuvent pas être recyclés d'après les
premières estimations de l'agglomération
versailles grand parc 7000 sapins ont
été récoltés puis broyés dans une
démarche écologique donc ce broyat il
peut être utilisé soit en paillage et
peut être un petit peu acide donc on
peut potentiellement le mélanger avec
d'autres types de broyage d'autres
heures pour mettre au pied des plantes
ou bien il sert très bien pour tout ce
qui est pour la délimitation des allées
ou pour en fait en tant que désherbant
naturel parce que comme il est acide il
permet voilà d'avoir ses usages et
ensuite pendant l'été le broyat
maintient l'humidité aux soldes et cela
vous évite d arrosage cela vous fait
faire des économies d'eau naissant
syrien pour mon venir chercher leurs
broyat à partir du mercredi 26 janvier
entre 10h et 12h ou de 14h à 16h au parc
maurice meluc
une bourse d'études pour les jeunes
trappistes allait proposer par le
rappeur kery james et les footballeurs
nabil fekir et bryan dabo une bourse de
12 mille euros via l'association ac es
apprendre comprendre entreprendre servir
il faut être titulaire du baccalauréat
et habiter trappe pour pouvoir
candidater pour postuler à la bourse
envoyez un mail à l'adresse qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran bourse à c
es @ gmail point com les inscriptions
sont ouvertes jusqu'à dimanche 30
janvier minuit
ce soir à 18h30 sur tv 78,2 vous avez
rendez vous avec le 7-8 culture
l'émission vous proposera notamment de
découvrir maxime grisard ce musicien
d'achères de 15 ans et joue du
violoncelle et du piano depuis son plus
jeune âge et il participe actuellement
au world vie jeunes juniors un concours
de musique classique l'illinois a besoin
de 500 vote pour passer à l'étape
supérieure focus sur son histoire avec
céline charles
[Musique]
on
je m'appelle monsieur lézard j'ai 15 ans
joue du violoncelle et le piano le
troisième mouvement concerto pour
violoncelle de dvorak n'a plus de secret
pour maxime à seulement 15 ans le
violoncellistes et pianistes se produit
régulièrement en france et à l'étranger
il a gagné plusieurs concours dont la
catégorie instruments de l'émission
prodige de france 2 qui l'a fait
connaître au grand public et a déjà
enregistré un disque chez warner
classique j'ai commencé le piano à 7 ans
au conservatoire h f et après un an plus
tard j'ai commencé le violoncelle où il
y avait un disque de avec des oeuvres de
rachmaninov
comme j'aimais beaucoup inscrit à neuf
ans au conservatoire de saint germain en
laye il le passe en seulement quatre ans
le garçon qui ne vient pourtant pas
d'une famille musicienne s'entraîne
jusqu'à 35 heures par semaine un talent
et du travail qui lui font vivre de
beaux moments j'aime bien fun avec
concert jouait pour les gens et ça va
faire plaisir c'est pour ça qu'on fait
de la musique on ressort il avait joué
devant un mur de berlin en 1989 après
geste après la chute j'avais envie de
faire comme hymne du coup je suis allé à
berlin j'ai joué devant un mur et
j'aimais bien les gens hésitaient
comptant un peu d'argent voici et du
coup je m'achetais des partitions je
jouais dans la rue il ya des musiciens
italiens qui - écouté pendant plus d'une
heure et après ils sont venus me voir et
m'ont invité à faire des concerts en
italie il représente actuellement la
france howard visionnent musique
conteste dans la catégorie junior un
concours en ligne avec une finale prévue
fin février à vienne passer en finale ce
serait con parce que je pourrais jouer
avec marquez passé mais quel est le
grand prix e prix peut
participer à des concerts
vous pouvez voter gratuitement pour
maxime sur le site de world vision
jusqu'au 29 janvier
[Musique]
et le 7-8 culture c'est ce mardi soir
sur tv 60,18 célia gars tsongo vous
emmènera également aux arcades du lac à
montigny le bretonneux l'une des
réalisations les plus emblématiques de
ricardo beau fils l'architecte espagnol
s'est éteint le 14 janvier dernier à
l'âge de 82 ans on va lever les yeux
vers le ciel pour refermer ce journal le
parc aux étoiles situé à triel-sur-seine
permet de s'initier à l'astronomie au
travers et d'animations ludiques le site
offre également la possibilité
d'observer les astres mathilde franco
observer les étoiles à travers la plus
grande lunette astronomique de france et
contempler les astres c'est possible au
parc aux étoiles deuxième site le plus
haut d'île de france il est situé en
plein coeur de la forêt de l'hautil à
triel-sur-seine sa position lui permet
de s'éloigner de la pollution lumineuse
le musée au sein du parc permet d'en
découvrir un peu plus sur l'astronomie
et l'astronautique grâce à un médiateur
scientifique
la visite se déroule dans cette première
galerie commence il y à peu près
13,5 6 milliards d'années dans ce qu'on
appelle communément big bang
progresse vers la formation des galaxies
des explications sur des phénomènes plus
complexe que par exemple le trou noir la
formation des systèmes planétaires la
seconde galerie du musée s'articule
autour d'événements majeurs comme le
premier satellite artificiel spoutnik ou
encore l'arrivée de l'homme sur la lune
en 1969 et pour les plus passionnés la
grande lunette astronomique est ouverte
au public
elle permet d'admirer le soleil le jour
ainsi que la lune et les planètes la
nuit de charlas paul donc qu'il
interdisait
en
exceptionnel jusque là tout le monde est
de médiation scientifique en france
autre outil cette camionnette nommé
léonard en hommage à leonard de vinci
premiers ingénieurs de france le parc
aux étoiles sillonnent ainsi les
yvelines pour apporter la science en
dehors de ses murs mais audard c'est
aussi ce télescope de type dobson qui
nous permettent d'intégrer des sites
d'observation un peu partout sur notre
territoire rendre accessible
l'astronomie et la science au plus grand
nombre et susciter la curiosité
scientifique dès le plus jeune âge voici
l'ambition du site qui rend les vacances
scolaires il organise des ateliers
pratiques pour les enfants de 5 à 16 ans
il dispose même de sa propre chaîne
youtube du permettant de vulgariser
certains sujets toujours avec un aspect
ludique
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité et belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]